la moitié des enfants de la planète ces
victimes de la pauvreté de la guerre et
du sida c'est un rapport accablant qu'a
rendue publique ce matin l'unicef
aujourd'hui plus d'un milliard d'enfants
dans le monde sont en péril hervé dino
dans son rapport intitulé l'enfance en
danger
l'unicef fournit une photographie de la
situation des enfants dans le monde
une photographie bien sombre plus d'un
milliard d'enfants seraient en péril car
victimes de la pauvreté des guerres et
du sida ce rapport recense plusieurs
privation de ballades qui hypothèquent
gravement leur avenir
640 millions d'enfants ne disposent pas
de logement adéquat 400 millions n'ont
pas accès à l'eau salubre 200 sont 10
millions ne bénéficient pas de soins
on retiendra également que 140 millions
d'enfants le plus souvent des filles ne
sont jamais allés à l'école et pourtant
la quasi totalité des gouvernements de
la planète s'est engagé à respecter les
droits de l'enfant mais l'unicef
considère que cet engagement restera
lettre morte tant que les nations ne
consentiront pas de réels efforts
financiers
l'enfance est en danger pas pour de
mystérieuses réseau sortie de notre
imagination mais bien à cause de choix
délibéré effectué par les gouvernements
et ce sur le pouvoir
si la pauvreté persiste ce n'est pas
pour rien la guerre ne surgit pas de
nulle part le sida ne se propage pas
tout seul
tout cela c'est le résultat de nos choix
le document de l'unicef montre également
que la pauvreté n'est pas l'apanage des
nations sous développés au cours des dix
dernières années la proportion des
enfants vivant dans des ménages à faible
revenu a augmenté dans onze des quinze
pays dits industrialisés